that said we're business
yeah good morning ladies and gentlemen
fellow councillors welcome to the
planning policy subcommittee meeting
before we go any further and I do any
more introductions I need to record the
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit chamber
there's one behind you
there's obviously one here where you
came in our assembly point is in the
public carpark at the side of the Civic
suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission by the council
staff please note this meeting will be
audio recorded and can I request you
turn off or put on sight on any mobile
phones thank you as I said welcome to
the meeting this morning my name is Dave
sparing members of this committee are
councillors Stanley councillor Mason and
councilor mrs. Weston will be present
today the other officers from Rockford
district council we have here mr. Dan
good MIRR at the Ender who is the senior
strategic planner
Sean Scranton who's the MD of Rockford
district counsel and Sonya Worthington
who is the Democratic Democratic
Services officer just to give you an
outline on this this meeting this is a
meeting held in public it is not a
public meeting which means only members
of the committee may ask questions
having said that if there are any
questions that you have concerns about
by the time we've finished our
negotiations on our discussions you are
very welcome to report or question any
of your district councillors this
committee has no authority to make final
decisions they are all made by the
District Council we only make
recommendations or ideas or views but no
decision is made by this small group of
people it is all down to the District
Council ultimately to either agree or
disagree with our recommendations
I believe that's pretty much covered the
issues
we'll have to go through a few of the
formalities initially and then I am
guessing that most of you are here to
talk about items number seven and eight
on the agenda so we will move that
straight up to the top of the list so
that you can all if you wish to stay
after that you've discussed that point
you're very welcome
if you wish to leave after we've
discussed the item in relation to
gypsies and travellers you may you're
welcome to leave apologies from absence
we've have apologies from council George
Iona and councillor june lammle okay
thank you no members attending counts
the ward councillor row can I expect the
minutes of the meeting of the 24th of
September as a gray gentleman
appearances yes thank you to receive any
declarations of interest none okay we're
now moving on to item number seven which
is the new local plan evidence base
South Essex gypsy and traveler
accommodation assessment dated 2019 I'll
pass on to mr. Goodman now to give you a
brief appraisal of the situation as you
can see those these reports are quite
lengthy I'll show you the paperwork
involved in some ships in travel
accommodation assessment that have been
taken across the whole of Essex and now
identified some pitch needs for for
gypsies and travellers up to the Year
2033
because of the emerging plan periods for
our both the local plan and the South
Wessex joint strategic plan being to
2038 there was a need to revise this
evidence to take into account that
five-year period at the end whilst also
taken into account that there had been
some changes to the supply situation
since the evidence was produced in
particular two new sites becoming
occupied in the district so the the
evidence being presented is not
particularly different from that which
members have already seen
however there are slight changes to to
the need figures that have arisen from
that piece of work and the the piece of
work specifically finds that there's 18
additional pitch is needed for
households that meet the planning
definition of a traveler three
additional pitch is needed for
households which are unknown whether
they meet that definition of a traveler
and 11 additional pitches for households
that are considered not to meet the
definition of a traveler the council is
required to plan for all of those needs
but the way in which it has to differs
depending on whether or not that a
particular household is considered to
meet the planning definition of a
traveler and that need is phased over
time so we have a relatively high degree
of need in the short term between 2016
and 2020 one of 14 two and nine and then
across the the ranger of the emerging
plan period there is an there is a total
of seven additional pitches
I suppose that's although I was planning
on saying on that so I'd like to say I
mean it is really what members have
already seen but extended across a
slightly longer plan period to align
with the emerging plans obviously
members we are having to talk with other
councils regarding an overall strategic
plan for the whole of Southeast Essex
which I know Dan is also heavily
involved in but is there any questions
from members that you wish to to quote
catch mice and code Thank You chairman I
hope I've chosen the right the right
paper it's been very difficult to pick
out you know which like issues fit with
this but we we've become aware of issues
of transit sites before in this in this
committee and I'm still not completely
clear in planning terms what they mean
and how they can be controlled in
particular I'm concerned about them
becoming somehow a transit
and then becoming permanent so can the
officer please explain to me the release
and the rest of the committee and
anybody else present what a transit site
is where the district council currently
has thoughts over where they might be
sited the extent to which they expect
them to be used and for what periods and
how they how the council will consider
ensuring that they don't become suddenly
permanent thank you okay well a transit
site is really a site that would be
occupied on a very short-term basis so
it's not any particular households home
base if you like it's a site that would
be occupied on a short-term basis as
that household was traveling so it may
only be occupied for a period of one
night it may only may be occupied for a
period of of one week so the need for a
transit so it has been identified on a
countywide basis but generally there's
not considered to be a consensus that
there's sufficient demand in each
constituent district or borough to to
provide a transit so it provides several
transit sites so there is a piece a
program of work that's beginning to
start that hasn't really progressed yet
at the Essex Planning Officers
Association level considering how the
authorities as a whole all all the
authorities in Essex might plan for a
transit so it's somewhere in Essex and
now you know I mean the the sites would
typically be managed and therefore you
know exactly how long a person household
was entitled to stay on that site would
be managed but there's no suggestion at
this stage that you know that there's
there's a need and acute need for a
transit so it within Rochford districts
but clearly there's a recognized need at
the county level to plan for for one so
so whilst generally we're talking about
sites that meet households needs as a
home if you like
the the need figures discussed in this
report don't directly relate to the need
for transit sites I would like to come
back German because I think we're all
aware there from time to time there is
transit through our district I live very
close to Clemens Hall and I know within
the last nine months have been at least
two incursions as I call them and at the
time of an election there was a further
incursion and there's been other
incursions across across the district
particularly around the swaying swaying
park area so to my mind what's what's
going to be the best chair Menards I'd
say and this is for members to consider
obviously with offices what's best to
allow this sort of thing to happen
unauthorized occupation of land or is it
best to bite a bullet and think about a
transit site you can control I think
John you've here hit the nail on the
head there as you know I was heavily
involved in all those incidents so I'm
fully aware of what the I mean we were
tracking the travelers as they were
going through Southend it wasn't a
question of when are they going to turn
up for him Roger it's just a question of
where so we were very aware of that I
think this is a question that we need to
discuss more fully with down as the
planning officers and as a council as a
whole which policy does the council want
to go down good bit Sean on that issue
chairman I mean I think as dan has
indicated there is an acceptance that
there may very well be a need for a
transit site somewhere in Essex and
there has been an ongoing debate over
some while in order to try and unpack
that issue and see whether it's possible
to find a suitable location for a
transit site I guess what I'd say to
members is and that's a subject that you
know it needs further discussion I
suspect that probably 11 districts in
the county would absolutely be delighted
if wrought should provide a transit site
because you know the challenge is for
all of the this
Dick's in the county to try and address
that issue and if someone steps up and
says well we'll have a transit site in
Richard then it will become the transit
site for the county and that may not be
quite what members we'd like in terms of
the movement of of those travelers
around the the county during the the
traveling period in the summer I'm sorry
to say that sounds a bit like project
theatre so I think the council and all
the councils in this part of Essex South
Essex and in particular under the
organization of a seller should think
seriously about what sort of transit
sites provisions should be made
I think it's project fear to turn around
and say well if we have one in our
district it will become one for the
whole of Essex clearly it needs to be
wider thinking take on board what you're
saying John but I think we're we're
talking with the other councils about
strategic developments across the whole
of South East Essex this is part of the
conversation that needs to be had as how
we're going to have it we're talking to
as you know South End Castle Point basil
Dan Turek on a regular brentwood on a
regular basis on all sorts of other
issues for future planning and i think
this is one that as a council we have to
address we can bring it up through this
through this planning policy as a full
council to decide and give some guidance
to dan in conjunction with discussions
with other councils but I think Shawn
has got a point that if we put our hand
up everybody else you can take a step
back I think that is a fair point but we
need to work as an area which is what
we're doing in every other aspect of
future development this is just another
aspect of that development chairman can
that become a recommendation from this
subcommittee I have no problem with that
that we can make a recommendation to
full council that we consider this I'm
sure you can put it into your plans for
the future down when we have when you
have discussions with other councils and
see where we go but I think we need to
discuss it at full council first to see
the the view of the rest of the council
yeah Chris you wanted to say something
Thank You chairman the transi so it
sounds good but the thing is who's going
to control it what what monies are
involved in getting that transit so it
and so on and so on I mean there is
there was a lot if it's between councils
then is every case we're going to put in
some sort of value into the pot tutor
moment save yet the so it's going to be
where every is gonna be could be in
every forest for goodness sake but it
could be anywhere in Essex so that's
that's something to be somebody who come
all later I've got how can I just answer
that one I would suggest that if we can
go down this road we would try and
incorporate Essex County Council will
have this work in real a close working
relationship with the gypsy traveller
group they already operate some sites in
the county when I've been to was in
Colchester where the county administer
this so I would suggest this could be a
way ahead but I say I think this would
be subject to discussion further down
the road I mean none of us have gonna
bury our heads in the sand this has got
to be addressed one way or another it's
just a form that which format we go
through thank you
I have asked five questions that I was
expected to get some answers from the
officer I sent them to Michelle as well
but that hasn't I thought oh okay okay
so unless anybody else has got any
questions on this we have a
recommendation that the subcommittee
resolves that the South Essex GTI a
dated 2019 attached and appendix I be
noted as evidence and published on the
council website in addition we recommend
that further discussion is held at
county district council level to discuss
potential transit sites and our views of
locations within the county
now I'm sorry sir this is just just
members only is that acceptable to
members yeah yeah okay thank you very
much we move on now to item number 8 on
the agenda over to you again Dan this is
the chiptune traveler issues papers and
sustainability appraisal regulation 18
consultation sorry okay so a decision
was made by members of council members
on the 13th of October that the priority
for the strategic planning team should
be the preparation of a gypsy and
traveler issues paper which sets out the
identified challenges and options for
meeting the accommodation needs of the
traveling gyptian traveler community in
the district in the future so the the
paper that has been presented to members
is is that is that paper which sets out
a variety of different issues and
options relating to the ways in which
sites might come forward where those
sites could be different options for how
we might meet that need and also some
discussion about the types of criteria
that should be used to decide whether a
particular sites would be suitable or
not it is accompanied by a
sustainability appraisal which is
required by legislation and that
considers the sustainability in economic
environmental and social terms of the
different options discussed so I think
it would be useful at this point to say
that with regards to one particular site
that's listed the site along Eastwood
Road we have been advised in the last 24
hours by the agent of the landowner that
they they no longer consider their site
available for that use as a result
members may consider
that it's appropriate to remove the site
from the from the consultation paper as
a key test of of sites coming forward is
that they are deliverable and one aspect
of that is obviously availability so
moving on the paper itself obviously it
has been written on the basis of
identifying the needs that Rochford
district half and that's obviously been
informed by item sevens report and
broadly considering how we might go
about meeting those needs particularly
in the context of Mitchell ins form and
concerns about its deliver ability and
therefore our recommendation to members
is that we consult the public on this
paper for a period of six weeks in which
time members of the public will be
encouraged to provide their views on the
challenges and options presented and
after the consultation we can obviously
consider which avenues the council
thinks it's most appropriate to go down
can I just clarify to our visitors here
today if you're under any illusions or
misunderstandings the reason that 340
370 was on the agenda for potential
sites was because the previous owner had
put it forward when we the council goes
out for its statutory call for sites
while we were led to believe that a
letter would be forthcoming from the new
owner saying that he wished to withdraw
this from being available
we couldn't withdraw it from the
paperwork until we had written
confirmation we have now got written
confirmation that he wishes this site to
be withdrawn so as it stands that site
is no longer available so unless
anybody's under him I hope that's
clarified the situation to everybody
I'm sorry some of you may have come
along just for that one issue but we
were in a position we couldn't withdraw
it from the written statement until we
had written confirmation from the new
owner so you're very welcome to stay but
I do have pretty
show that perhaps a lot of you have come
along just to that cell purpose I'm
sorry I
yet that is if if that is quite clear
the new owner
he's agent I have a copy of the letter
here has made it quite clear the land is
no longer available for gypsy and
traveler sir are you happy to take that
recommendation committee you no no just
now just three 4370 is withdrawn from
the list of potential site noted okay
yeah yeah Chris dan will come back but
let me yeah no we couldn't do anything
we were stuck weeding you the net we
were told the letter was coming until we
got it
we all knew yesterday but there's
nothing yeah
no there's nothing we could do John we
were stuck yeah yeah no no no no yeah
don't do it a drink yeah would you yeah
oh it is up there in it
sorry chip business ok visitors and
members can we reach start the meeting
I know councillor Stanley members can we
can we go on visitors can we we can we
can we carry on now please with the
meeting caster Stanley I know you've got
some questions for Dan that you've
submitted previously off you go down
you've got them all there i think i mean
regarding the consultation of the set of
community I mean the recommendation
before members is that is that well
there's a recommendation to council that
we go out to public consultation on this
for six weeks and obviously at that
point they the wider community will be
encouraged to to respond to the
consultation so that is a stage at which
the concert well every community will be
consulted regarding how permission might
be granted to unauthorized sites
particularly when some are in appeal and
and another some perhaps restrictive on
the number of pitches on their plot and
similar well I mean realistically you
know we do know that there are currently
two appeals on traveller sites waiting
to be heard and obviously the you know
subsequent to this to this consultation
members will have to consider you know
which options we pursue and if that is
authorizing any existing unauthorized
sites that that that have had appeals
heard they will obviously have to take
into account the outcomes of those
appeals and you know
and it may be appropriate to to allow
applications to come forward to be
considered by the council on those
unauthorized sites on the basis of the
capacity I mean the capacity of sites is
something that's going to need to be
considered on a case-by-case basis so
for four sites which are currently
occupied by travelers who who have no
desire to expand this so I would
obviously have to be considered if the
council decided to look at allowing
additional pictures on any sites
regarding the compatibility of this with
government policy on on the Greenbelt
it's true that the travelling travelers
sites would ordinarily be considered
inappropriate development however we we
have to take note of recent appeal
decisions which have given the extent of
unmet need in the district's greater
weight and so we have to take a look at
the options and consider whether that
scale of unmet need outweighs any
potential harm to the Greenbelt and
obviously that has to consider what harm
would actually occur to the Greenbelt
clearly if we're talking about existing
unauthorized sites that may have existed
for a long period of time that harm now
has a degree of permanence so so there
is no I suppose there's no this Odyssey
are not seeking to challenge government
policy but it's obviously looking to
balance competing competing requirements
in terms of the the matters to be
considered and whether this includes
waste water clean water and waste in
general I mean one chapter of the of the
report looks at the kind of criteria
that could need to be considered when
making some kind of appraisal of a
potential site and so if something is a
material planning consideration then
obviously it will have to be looked at
when the council considers its options
issues that are not Material planning
considerations and that includes
potential loss of property value could
not be taken into a
through any planning process and I think
that probably answers question five
about loss of property value like I say
I mean it's no it's not being considered
a material planning consideration and
therefore cannot be considered in that
decision-making process and if members
have any other questions good you will
come back to yeah Thank You chairman
where we have unauthorized sites and
obviously there in the green belt as we
already know that there is there is some
failing in the community of close to
those sites that they are in that are
kept in a deplorable way and not in the
way that is normally expected of a
resident to behave in as much as waste
and what-have-yous on those sites and so
with this being in the settled community
as we've already mentioned that we go to
or try to put those sites in the central
community what have we done to ask that
community about those settled sites that
we are proposing to do about the
unauthorized settled site so it's Iran
at the moment and okay so I think just
on one of those points I mean the the
paper itself lists a number of options
and some of the options include
authorizing sites which are relatively
remote from from the set of community
and some of the options are clearly
quite clearly closer I mean at one point
the the issues paper does consider the
kinds of the kinds of issues that or the
kind of facilities that sites might need
to include when they come forward and
there is similar to the transit site
issue there is a program of work planned
with the EPA about potentially having
some kind of design guide but for new
traveler sites so traveler sites that
come forward in designed and laid out in
a in the best possible way in terms of
existing sites I mean obviously we we
have to be careful what is a planning
consideration and what is not you know I
mean typically speaking you know some
degree of
treatment of foul water does fall within
the planning system and to some degree
it doesn't and you know if there are
existing issues then I would say that
they would be treated in a different
process - this one really this is
looking at whether or not there's a
planning justification to potentially
authorize some of those unauthorized
unauthorized sites and at that point you
know treatment of waste may be able to
be considered but only in proportion at
detail and obviously there has to be
based on on submitted details rather
than necessarily experience of that site
so I suppose that that's what I would
say about about those okay those
questions that's fine I just got two
more which I've thought about in-between
if that's all right with you has there
been any more development to the
Michelin farm sites as this was first
placed in February 2014 to develop it
into a traveler site as the council has
a considerable of nine million in its
reserves and has spent this to this date
and has has got this to the state what
what we go to are we moving towards this
development with this with money from
the council or is this going to be just
another another thought that where the
council's going and not making any
progress to them included is that
there's an allocated site at Mitchell
ins farm and there's currently believe a
planning application on that site that
for business development that actually
squid's the area of the travelers site
the land I believe has recently changed
ownership so it's that new owner that
has has submitted the
has submitted the planning application I
guess what I'd say to members is if you
feel that there is something that the
council should do
through its MTFs the budget process its
capital program etc then the opportunity
to raise that is coming next month
through the through through the
consideration of the the council's
budget for 2019 to 20 just last question
you know when will this thank you very
much for the literature and everything
you've done for the travelers and it's
quite expletive as it stands but when
will the cats will deliver this
travelers sight that we're so so want
remember that consultation with the
settled community should be paramount
before we actually go there and and also
that there needs to be addressed to the
government policy of settlements in a
settled area in a settled community and
so I suppose one of the points I mean
the like I say the recommendation to
Council is this this this goes out to
public consultation for a period of six
weeks so at that stage we will encourage
public comment on the options that are
listed but at this stage they are broad
options generally kind of areas for us
to go down as opposed to necessarily
specific solutions in terms of
timescales I mean it would really depend
on on the options that council chose to
pursue clearly authorizing an
unauthorized site that's already
occupied is a much quicker process than
potentially allocating new land for it
for a new site so I mean it ultimately
depends critically on on the options
pursued by members
as I say I mean authorizing existing
sites is is potentially one solution and
that's covered in the in the issues
paper whereas you know allocating new
land that would require a development
plan document which is you know was this
may be one the first stage in that
process would still take a considerable
amount of time to put put together you
know that I suppose that that's all we
can say at this time but obviously
subsequent to the consultation I think
there will need to be a conversation
about what has been borne out of the
consultation and you know what the
council thinks is the most appropriate
option moving forward you know this is
kind of an information gathering
exercise and to make the options clear
but it's not necessarily the process
right now whereby one or more or two of
those options are picked and pursued
with you know that that's more I suppose
for following on from the consultation
is the council looking for a response
from the community on all the sites or
is it specific questions so one answer
now shoot it once to add a bit before we
want to Jonin - yes - I'm just from a
very a very practical standpoint and I'm
not sure where this rumor has emerged
from if the subcommittee this morning
recommends to council that the
consultation paper be published for for
that consultation period of six weeks
the consultation will be with the whole
community it won't be restricted to the
traveler community it's it's a
consultation with all of all of the
residents of the district so it will be
an opportunity for everyone in the
community to put forward their views
whether from a set of community or the
traveller community on the issues that
are set out in the paper
right moving on John oh yeah okay thanks
thank ya I appreciate that thank you
very much John I think one of the issues
that was raised by Chris can be easily
answered in regards to the research that
Essex County Council are doing in
regards to gypsy and traveler sites and
to do their their various programs that
they're looking at which I believe will
go in the Essex design guide which I
think will bring a lot of comfort to a
lot of people in that it will be quite
prescriptive in some of the requirements
and I think the whole idea is when we
look at what that guidance is going to
be it would be worthwhile bringing it in
as special planning guidance within you
know our own policy so that when we have
any chips in traveler sites that are
coming forward it will actually be
prescriptive in as much as that how the
site is made up the fact that it needs
to have running water electricity all
the various issues with regard to sewage
and I believe that they are looking at
how they're going to bring that forward
can you confirm that place yes so so
excess County Council are looking on
behalf of the Essex Planning Officers
Association at developing some kind of
design guidance for trips in traveler
sites so at this stage it's it's kind of
at the scoping stage so they're
considering the kinds of issues that the
design guidance would need would need to
cover and and clearly at a point in time
once that's advanced no this council
could choose whether or not it wants to
you know endorse that that guidance at
this stage it's not exactly fleshed out
what will fall into that guidance and
what will not but clearly it will have
some kind of advice and guidance
surrounds the layout of sites and for
example on particularly large sites
provision of green space and
things like that so it's about exactly
what is in the site that is coming
forward whereas I suppose the issues
paper is looking for mostly apps
actually a you know a program of being
able to bring sites forward so so yes I
mean they are working on that it's not
yet a stage where it resembles anything
but but clearly once it's advanced to a
certain point then then then Council can
consider consider what's in it yeah
thank you
I I think I think it's very important
for the settled community to have
comfort where we do have sites which are
going to be located within the settled
community or close to that settled
community and obviously if that is going
to be the case there needs to be a great
degree of comfort as far as the settled
community would be with regard to a
Gyptian traveler community or a group
coming in so that they were confident
that whatever was going to be set down
they would have confidence in the fact
that that site would be well managed and
that it would be under that type of
description I think that I'm just
advocating that concern that we need to
take on board within our own Council to
make sure that comes forth I'm sure and
as soon as we have something concrete to
work on whether it will be discussed
within the planning and or full council
to ensure that it seems to make common
sense that you wouldn't make sure you
included that in any future approval for
planning application or development if
you have to so you have to you chairman
I've I've got three questions and
they're in pretty diverse areas so I
wonder do you want me to do them one at
a time or drop them all out and see
where we go okay take a while okay
you'll certainly have a breakdown the
first one needs to ask further questions
about gt1 which is otherwise known as
mission his farm although I've never
seen it as a farm strangely though
but there you are and what I'd like to
understand chairman from from offices in
particular I think mister scrappin can
desist is why what issues has the
council encountered or indeed County
encountered any council encountered with
regard to delivery of that site because
I don't understand what has gone wrong
more particularly you know what has
caused it not to be delivered so when
the managing director asks have members
got ideas I want to know what the
problem is before I can have any ideas
on that one chairman thank you I mean I
don't actually I'm not sure I've got any
easy answers in terms of in terms of
michelin's farm
I mean clearly in the dim and distant
past it was a site that was put forward
it was tested through the the Local Plan
process all it was it was core strategy
and allocations plan it was tested
through that process and it was in
principle found to be a site that could
make a contribution towards traveler
accommodation there was a view though
the tests are I think more stringent now
there was a view that the site had the
potential to be deliverable but of
course as I think councillor Mason is
aware Michelin's farm has got a
complicated and checkered history and
those of us who occasionally have gone
past on the train will have seen it in
all sorts of disarray over over the
years in terms of the
materials and Psalm that were deposited
on the site and fires and goodness knows
what so it has got a a checkered history
and there was I think concern about the
contaminant levels of contamination on
the site what the implications that
would have for deliverability and for
residential accommodation so it's
changed hands now there has been a
discussion with the new land owner about
the deliverability of a traveler site
there the planning application that's
been submitted to date as I said earlier
does exclude the traveler site from from
that planning application so it doesn't
prevent that from potentially coming
forward but I guess we're in a situation
of having to determine whether or not
there is a likelihood that a private
development would take place on that
site for traveler accommodation or
whether indeed there is a willingness
for there to be a substantial public
investment in bringing forward they
publicly provided site to make a
contribution towards towards the the
traveler needs in the district so it's a
complicated picture and there's no
there's no easy answer I think I have to
I mean of course I'm completely aware of
the history of the site and in
particular you know I was on the review
committee when you know there was a
considerable amount of time spent on
considering the safety of the site as
before the event and the incidents and
afterwards but nevertheless that's been
some time ago and I've been pleased that
it was some time ago and there haven't
been any further incidents of note what
I can't actually understand is why
there'd been no positive action taken by
the council in this period and
that answer doesn't tell me why the
council has not taken as far as I'm
aware as a member any positive action
well only to say chairman I think that's
a question for the council not
necessarily for me I'm not trying to
sidestep that but that may there will be
an issue that councilor Mason wants to
raise that came cilinder course witness
when this item is is considered next
month just to clarify win this item you
mean item eight correct okay okay
I'm sure Randall members will join me in
asking questions my second question he
relies upon the fact that I've been on
the council a long time and there have
been quite a few traveler applications
for special circumstances over that time
and I can and I know mr. Scranton
remembers them because we've had urgent
conversations just just before many of
them and I just I don't know what I
don't know is because my memory is not
perfect is how many of those which are
currently subject to temporary
permission are included in this
consultation because if they were
granted for special circumstances then
they're not they're not available for as
a generality necessarily for usages of
traveler sites in future in other words
once the circumstances of special
certain have expired then it wouldn't
necessarily expect them to continue so
how many of those following to fall into
that category
well I mean there are there are two
temporary permissions that have been
identified in this in in the paper I
mean one of them that was relatively
recently determined were on appeal was
apportioned wait for the needs of a
child on that site but that does not
mean that that need does not exist so
there is still an obligation on the
council to provide for it albeit clearly
the the inspector has given weight to
the needs of a child in that particular
case so when the council comes in to see
their
consider whether or not that site is a
good site to authorize permanently it
will obviously have to consider whether
or not the needs for the child was was
the only if you like the only factor in
in in having to grant that permission
and if there are any fundamental reasons
why sites in that particular location is
not acceptable in planning terms so on
the other and temporary site my
understanding is we have a planning
application in now to extend that period
and it has only just come in I believe
and and they will obviously have to be
some consideration there as to whether
or not the circumstances on that sites
have changed whether or not there is
justification to grant temporary
permission or indeed a permanent
permission on that site and that will
obviously have to consider its
acceptability in planning terms and also
the extent of unmet need in the district
and realistically whether or not there
are as an alternative site where those
people if they were grant and if they
were refused planning permission could
go because if there is not then in the
likelihood of an appeal situation you
know we are likely to again have to have
to consider our arguments about whether
an unmet need is outweighs the need
outweighs any harm to the Greenbelt so
in both of those cases my understanding
is temporary permissions were granted
partly on the basis that inspectors
considered it was realistic that that
Michelin's form may have been delivered
by the end of that temporary period and
therefore may allow the residents on
that site alternative accommodation at
the end of that expiry clearly if we do
not expect Michelin's farm to be
delivered at the end of that expiry then
then we will have to consider whether or
not or how we can provide alternative
accommodation for those existing
households and whether or not that
includes granting them permanent
consents so I'm not aware of any
temporary permissions other than those
two
but it may be that they now fall within
the category of unauthorized if those
temperate missions have have expired and
in which case I mean I suppose what I
would say is that you know clearly the
council will need to look at its options
and if it and if it considers that
authorizing unauthorized sites is a good
option it will need to consider though
those sites on on a site by site basis
and if there are fundamental reasons why
the circumstances on that site mean it
is not suitable for a permanent
permission then it will have to
obviously consider that but at this
stage they are listed as as options and
I suppose areas for consideration
but I suppose offices at this point have
not given given too much detailed
analysis into the specifics about each
of those listed sites hopefully that
helps yeah I understood all of that
clearly the lack of positive action on
gt1 Mitchell ins for moszer is a
particular issue that the council will
have to come to grips with in a planning
sense but so if we're having a planning
we're having a consultation with the
public but those are material factors as
to whether they might or might not see
those as appropriate extensions of
permanent traveler sites and I would
expect that the consultation to draw
attention to that otherwise you can't
get a meaningful consideration by the
public either so you know I'm not happy
that there are two in there where there
are certain circumstance already
applying which the public need to know
about to be able to consider them as to
whether they they consider they should
become permanent so that's an issue for
the subcommittee to consider because
it's material you want me to go on okay
well I fully appreciate what you're
saying I'm not quite sure that the
public would have the expertise to
understand the implications of some of
these things that you're saying it would
just be well no or yes while you and an
officers may understand the intricacies
you are asking members of the public who
don't have our in-depth background to
some of this to comment on issues that
they may not realize the implications of
some of the situations you want I think
you misunderstood me chairman I'm going
to come back to you I think the public
needs to know that there are temporary
permissions and they are special
circumstances I wouldn't expect it to go
any further
chairman if it helps we could add a note
into the paper that that gives the
current planning status of unauthorized
sites I'm sorry I misunderstood what
you've said yeah you know hang on in
that can't done okay I appreciate thank
you on that point I think the point that
John was trying to allude to was the
original point that came up in tr9 where
as far as that particular site was
concerned the owner had withdrawn
permission for that site to be used so
now even though it's on that paper that
will need to be withdrawn I think John
was possibly alluding to the fact that
there are sites on here still which need
to have further notation on which may or
may not come forward because I noticed
Mitchell ins farm is is on there as
well and that may not come forward so it
may not be an option even though it's in
here that there needs to be something
set aside that changes are possible this
site may not be available I think that
is maybe and I guess what you were
trying to allude to it wasn't but I'm
happy to see the extension to that so
before we can to your last point join
perhaps we can put some wording in here
to cover these aspects the items have
been raised in this meeting should be
reflected in the recommendations to fall
Council yeah
okay John you got one more I've been
counting
[Laughter]
the sticks
with tra 12 which done wise in my ward
West and it's called Green Acres the
owner has written to me and said it is
not our intention for the site to be
used for travel and that's as far as I
want to divulge but I think it's
entirely appropriate for me to say that
on his behalf
he can't be here for other reasons so
the council needs to be anybody
I suppose the second question is follow
who says I take it then TRX well fine
the second part goes on because
residents have already looked in
particular on tra 12 they are saying
that's been taken and it's inaccurate so
what I would like to have ensured is
every single one of those maps is
checked for detail
because residents are in dignity okay
yep okay well I think if there's no
other questions I think we can pretty
much go down if subject to members
approval that the subcommittee
recommends to Council the gypsum travel
issues paper and accommodating an
accompanying sustainability appraisal as
attached at Appendix A and B
respectively be published for formal
publication consultation for six weeks
subject with the recommendations and
approvals which and those Sonia has made
a note of be included in the
recommendations members of agreeing with
that because I think you've got all the
bits and pieces and will that will be
the further recommendation with the
additions on okay thank you very much
okay right we'll go back to agenda items
now back onto agenda item 5 which is the
local plan local development scheme 2018
2021 yep so this is another revision to
our local development scheme as members
will no doubt be aware by now we are
required to keep an up-to-date timetable
for plan making this reflects revisions
to to the timetable including the
addition of a of a timetable for
obviously the consultation we've just
discussed and a potential timetable for
further iterations on this subject
subject to any decision by council its
rotate largely retains the already
agreed timetables for the south of 6
Georgia treaty plan and the local plan
but clearly if there are changes agreed
or suggested to those then we will
present that back to members in a later
subcommittee and so the recommendation
to members of the subcommittee is that
it's recommended to counsel that this
revised LDS
is adopted and I believe that it is
almost nearly almost identical to the
one that is already agreed just adding
those additional areas which I have
noted okay members is are there any
questions on this I think Dan's pretty
much explained it unless you got
anything yet Chris Cove
Thank You chairman I realized that with
the local plan of sites for development
but have we taken into consideration the
time scale of how the the local plan is
developing in as much as sites that have
now been allocated for development will
take takers probably way up to 2025 2030
the way the way the the sites are
working out and before we actually
allocate any more sites have we let's
let's make sure that we are getting
those developed in the time scale that
we want rather than exceeding onto the
time scale as far as I'm aware Chris
this is this is an issue that we've
raised even with our MP to try and
expedite the approved sites already now
you know as well as I do that we cannot
force developers to move any quicker
than we would like them to we would love
to have brought the land in we have very
limited powers as you're aware to
actually force them to move quicker than
they want to providing they meet their
criterias the periods and bits and
pieces it is a very frustrating
situation but that doesn't take away the
need that we still have as a council to
keep producing the five-year plans it's
as simple as that
we'd love to be as far as I'm aware so
I've got this wrong Shawn to be to be
forcing some of these developers to move
faster than they they would but they're
not you know they're sitting on land the
same as we do and while I have sympathy
for your comments
I don't quite know how we're gonna force
them to move faster but as I say we
still need to move our requirements for
the five-year plane and do you wanna
come in Sean on that or is that somebody
up pretty reasonably yeah John yes like
to kind of follow up on that yep because
that there are there are sites that seem
to have stalled they don't seem to have
got to planning permission and been
delayed yet alone yet alone got to the
very first step does that mean that
there's a possibility that those sites
those allocations of sites formal
allocation sites could be removed in
this new plan in other words there that
there they are a gap
could we I mean I won't to talk about
particular sites because this is not an
appropriate place but if it's if we know
that I landowner he's not gonna bring it
forward we know they're not gonna bring
it forward can we just take it out I
mean I'm not sure I'm aware of any of
the allocated sites that are not in the
process of being discussed for
development I think the difficulty is
that the development process is in
principle quite simple if it's one
single landowner and you know they get
the developer involved and they submit a
planning application unfortunately some
of the sites that are allocated are a
little bit more complicated in that have
multiple ownerships and there is a need
for those owners to reach an agreement
and an accommodation with the with with
the developer and between themselves
indeed so
I'm not aware of any any sites that are
not subject to discussions about
bringing them forward for development
but it does take longer sometimes then
the council the council would like and
that that is that is a risk when one's
looking at five-year supply and so
yeah so we've set out in our allocation
of sites in 2014 that we have an
expectation of sites delivering over
certain time periods and blocks of five
years so if if they don't then that's a
gap does that also also mean that other
sites can be that are further into the
future can actually turn around to us
and say deliver mine now
and that's a good point chairman and I
think we've we've accepted that
principle already in relation to for
example whole bridge where I think there
was a potentially two phases of
development there so we've accepted the
principle that planning application can
be granted across across that whole site
I think that the the risk that any local
authority has if a site takes longer to
come forward for development than
anticipated is an argument around five
years supply and whether or not in order
to stop that gap other sites have got to
be identified in order to in order to
ensure that there is a continuing five
year supply of development but those
members will be aware that is an
immensely complicated process in in a
Greenbelt district where the MPP F
indicates clearly that sites should only
be brought forward through a planning
local planning process through an
allocation process and that seems to be
the view that has generally been adopted
by the but by the government so it's
it's a it's it's a it's an interesting
an interesting question and I'm not sure
there's a there's an easy and easy
answer just to follow up so during this
new plan which we're talking about then
if a preferred options certain sites
become or areas with no sites become
more likely to proceed to allocation
then we could see where there are gaps
currently in our current plan the
emerging sites can take that place where
there's a greater keenness or greater
ability for the site to be delivered in
other words new sites could end up we've
not even just we've not even discussed
yet could end up in them in an emerging
plant and literally leapfrog the lot
because of gaps in our own delivery
delivery scheme yeah I mean I suppose in
principle but but I'm not I tend to
think that's probably unlikely and
certainly I don't think it would be
practical to consider the notion that a
site that's currently allocated for
housing is likely to to progress and
would be removed from a plan because
there are likely to be compensation
issues arising from that if the council
sought to try and take that to chairman
and it's on the record because there are
developers out there who think with
their new sites that are in the current
call for sites that they can bring them
forward fairly quickly I was trying to
understand within this orderly process
how that could happen
and I just say one thing to the
pencilled not to penciler that I wrote
various letter to the Rotorua District
Council and I was told over the phone
that you don't answer written letters
which are my it was horrifying so I hope
they'll take another in few
I did get in touch with Mike France
twice and he was also chairman if it if
it helps from from a managing director
the council does answer letters in
writing so if you've been given that
information I can only apologise
chairman could i interject there there
if there is an issue where if residents
write in on a planning application the
council doesn't reply to them but it
makes it clear that it doesn't reply to
objections support or observations on
planning applications to me to go back
to the point of the point at hand I'm
conscious of the fact that there are
there are very keen landowners who may
very well have submitted representations
through the call for sites who would
love their their their sites to be
developed for housing and they will
absolutely put forward through their
agents an argument that says hey Luc our
site here it's fantastic we can we can
bring this forward and we can solve all
your problems and I'm here to say
chairman that those people MIT should be
sadly disappointed the issue for the
council is that we we plan properly for
development in in the district and that
means that the council has to consider
the appropriate policies and allocations
through the that the plan making process
and that includes know that the the
joint strategic plan and and that is the
that is the process and I think I think
the council should rightly resist the
notion that the any an enthusiastic
owner of a Greenbelt site should somehow
or other at this juncture take
precedence over allocated sites or the
plan making Pro statement that is a very
important statement made by the managing
director which I hope is reproduced in
the minutes because there's a message
there for these developers who are
worrying my residents and this will
assist thank you
Sonia has got it in the minutes and it
will be made available to two members
very quick question yes because we've
had at least one yeah yeah
Thank You chairman with these many of
these sites and the pasture Lane will be
owned as or the owner of the part of the
land will be the developer could we find
and this is a question to the council
could we find ourselves with passes a
land owned by developers and not
developing in the next 15 years because
if we're going to continue with their
five-year plan of this sort is open fell
of this sort is he's allocated to build
onto a developer we could find the next
15 years with all these sites five I
don't know how many so as we do every
five years whether it be two sites or
one saw it per five years we could find
ourselves with a with a lump Elaine's
out there with no development on at all
and and we should this is the point what
well I think is being raised by the
council Mason is that if we've got sites
that a developer wants to develop and
can bring it forward quicker than those
ones that we've already passed should we
not be looking at them to to to
facilitate this just answered that one
he said we've just we've just gone
through that in relation to John's
question okay the recommendation is that
the draft local development scheme 2018
2021 attached at appendix I be adopted
agreed thank you and last but not least
item number six the new local plan
evidence-based South East Essex
strategic growth locations assessment in
2019 how do you go okay so this piece of
work is a piece of joint evidence that's
been prepared with officers from
Southend and castle point councils so at
this stage its lucky
it looked across Southeast Essex for
areas which were considered to
potentially have potential for what's
been defined a strategic scale growth so
strategic scale growth is is in the
order of 6,000 to 10,000 homes possibly
possibly more than that but as a as a
kind of filter for the purposes of this
assessment and it's the scale of growth
that's considered to be able to deliver
meaningful improvements to
infrastructure things like and use new
secondary schools you know meaningful
road improvements and things like things
like that so the purpose of the
assessment was really just to look
across South East Essex to see whether
there was any potential capacity for
development of that scale it has not
considered the specific capacity or the
specific infrastructure requirements of
that level of growth if this is a this
is an avenue that is that the council
goes down then obviously those kind of
considerations will have to come later
but broadly the conclusions of the
assessment were that the only sector in
the in the study area which could was
considered to have capacity for
strategic scale growth was sector D
which is I think has been called the
land north of Fawcett's farm and Garen's
Park so to the east of Rochford and west
of great Wakering it includes land
within both Oxford's administrative
boundary and south ends administrative
boundary and has been has been
considered all the sectors have been
considered against various high level
constraints things like European
environmental designations instead of
the more detail constraints that our
later piece of work would would look at
so the purpose of this stage really is
for is to provide an initial piece of
evidence suggesting one potential option
that may may warrant further exploration
it's not in any way shape or form a
decision being made by by the council
on the merits or otherwise of
development in that in that area it is
just like I say a piece of evidence to
inform where I suppose the direction of
travel in plan making in this in this
area in Germany I think this was singly
the most interesting paper amongst the
collection the first question is I think
Shawn can probably answer this one
sector D sounds remarkably like the area
that I seen Ian Seaside put forward you
know best part of 10 years ago for
20,000 houses on the borders if not
straddling it between Rochford district
and Southend is that is that broadly
correct thank you I'll just leave it at
that because I don't want to go into
whether they're going to reappear but
they might the second question relates
obviously what mr. Goodman just just
said which is reflected in the report is
that so this could relate to a
development of between 6,000 and 10,000
houses which very loosely equates to a
garden community which of course you
know has featured in our issues and
options consultation of 17-18 Wilkes I
also know from looking at key decisions
document that there was to be a number
of councils including this council were
to consider whether a a bid a request of
government for consideration of
community garden communities would have
been made last November because the
government has indicated I believe that
it wishes to know what ambitions there
are for that because there are there are
grounds to expect the government to
participate in infrastructure to the
extent to which sector D has now been
has now been identified can I ask has a
seller or this council mr. boat
relation to that particular item yeah
there was a bid process in fact the
advice that a seller received was that
we were a bit early in the in terms of
update there is a notion across South
Essex certainly leave aside South East
Essex there's certainly a notion
elsewhere in the in in South Essex that
Newgarden community or communities is
something that that should should be
examined as an option and but the advice
was that we were probably too early in
terms of bidding so we submitted an
expression of interest just to ensure
that you know next time out when there's
a further bidding round we hopefully
will get an opportunity to just submit a
bid to government for some resources
tour to help that person to sum up
German than this this is as an option
and clearly an option with constraints
that it's a possibility for a garden
community in Rockford district as part
of the new local plan
I don't quite know whether whether we
can go with that one John not because
I'm being particularly negative but I'm
not quite sure how we can reject that
that's what we've got n an option is it
not a lot if it's not an option for that
then it's not an option for anything
it's just a waste of paper because it
either it either
it either is an option within a new
local plan as a garden community with
the support of government in a scheme or
it's a waste of paper but we've got
we've got the appropriations and the
areas is already highlighted in the
report this is the very early tentative
stage and there's no reason why it can't
be progressed as part of the overall
conversations so chairman it decision
this is just nothing more than an
evidence-based document what I'd say to
members is there is a there's a process
that I mean in a sense there's two two
processes there's the council's own
Local Plan process but of course
councils signed up to the association of
southeast Explorer Thor authorities and
to the principle of preparing a joint
strategic plan and I think the intention
is that later in the year there will be
an issues and options paper emerging as
part of that joint strategic plan
working and as I think the council's own
issues and options paper flagged there
is an option of looking at a new garden
settlement called with will and I think
that that's something that will come
certainly through the the strategic view
and strategic issues and options
consultation of frog frog from from the
GS from the JSP and of course this is a
cost it is an evidence base to that on
the plan that we've just approved under
item five we are due to produce as a
council the preferred options in October
of this year surely if this is a this
this is at all at all an interest or a
viable potentially viable option
we would expect it to be developed to me
there be included oldest or excluded
from preferred options to attend if I'm
either that they're likely the
expectation is that the issues and
options for the GSP will be considered
prior to us getting to the point of
doing further work so there will be a
lead a strategic lead and will will will
reflect that in you know you know so the
next time I hear about this would be in
the JSP issues and options around the
spring if it's at all likely to be a
viable option correct correct correct
thank you yeah otherwise we have two
recommendations here which I think
bearing in mind the comments that both
Jordan and John have said that can be
reflected in the minutes yeah the
recommendations are that the South East
Essex strategic growth locations
assessment attached at appendix a be
noted as an evidence-based document and
published on the council's website and
number two that officer continue to work
with Southend castle point Borough
Council's and the duty to cooperate to
continue to address the cross boundary
issues which may have legal and
soundness implications for Oxford's
planning mate ruptures plan making okay
as we've said their comments councillor
Mason mr. Scranton have made
yeah cadet sutras chairman that might be
worth just referencing the fact that
that's also part of the Association of
South s it's local authorities you know
so there's a bigger picture reflected in
that and yet and that as well
so it's not just Castle point it's not
just come out and say okay members thank
you very much and this we have itemized
sorry I seem knowing right sorry
if she's not give us the document
feedback report so then the most
important one we've been talking about
for weeks over to you okay so this is
slightly belatedly a feedback report has
been produced to summarize upon the
issues and options consultation that was
held between December and March March of
2018 so the council is required to put
together a feedback reports to to help
discharge regulations in the town and
country local planning regulations and
at when a plan is submitted for
examination we would be expected to
reproduce evidence and a statement of
how people were consulted at at each
stage and how those people were
consulted so that's that's one of the
purposes of this report and the other is
obviously to provide any interested
parties with a way of of seeing what
comments have been received and an
initial officer response obviously to
some degree a lot of the issues and
comments were around matters that will
be will become clearer as the council
progresses with its plan making so it's
not always been possible to give a
conclusive response at this stage but it
has been an initial response based on
current information has been given in in
each case and it has been split up into
various chapters based on the
type of respondent so if an interested
party is particularly interested in
looking at how certain organizations or
individuals have responded they can they
can do so and it'll also splits the
topics up into the the chapter of the
issues and options document to which
they relates it as well as providing
some additional information about how
people how residents and businesses and
constitutes were engaged with and some
statistics around how many responded and
and how and the recommendations counsel
is that this is noted it forms a part of
the wider local plan evidence and can be
published on the council's website
albeit later than we would have liked
and I think that's some you know been
recorded well by this subcommittee
anyway but we need just to acknowledge
that so the public don't think that we
were completely comfortable with the
fact that there's been a long delay it's
obviously appropriate in the process to
ensure that the evidence is properly
recorded in the evidence base but I
think I'm more interested in what will
happen to it in the future because
there's some there's some some
interesting preferences views given by
public stakeholders and other
organizations and what what I could like
to be assured of is that this just won't
simply be recorded but through the rest
of the process including proceeding to
preferred options we do actually look
back on it and ensure that we comply
with it it sounds a bit like brexit but
actually it's a it's a microcosm of how
you know stakeholders and which are only
the residents
get to influence the final decision and
we have in this microcosm a quite large
decision locally about our local plant
do you know core plan over something
like another 20 years so can mr. Goodman
or Shawn assure me that this is a
dynamic document and it will be used at
every stage of the process to inform
what the council seats to put forward as
recommendations or intentions in the
next stages if we don't it becomes
totally valueless and I've got to
honestly say to you as you as you all
know through your post banks residents
don't think we listen this time and
we've said this several times and the
chairman said it several times we've got
to demonstrate that we are and the way
to demonstrate it is ensure that it's
referenced through the future of the
process I think I can answer that John I
don't think neither you nor I will allow
this not to happen I think it's as
simple as that
it had to be said had to be said but I I
say we've had this conversation
repeatedly through the process it's
there it's evidence-based and yes it
should be used castable yeah thank you
very much chairman I would like to thank
the officers this is this has been a
very very good piece of work which as
John has quite rightly said it should
enable us to draw on what our residents
have wanted within their own minds how
they see I know it's a very complicated
process the planning process but what we
have tried to do as far as our residents
are concerned is to give them the
choices that are really deep rooted
within them which are probably
fundamentally within the infrastructure
the facts where there is lack of
infrastructure that their needs and I
think where we're taking any plan
forward any needs
forward we need to actually reference
what is in here so we can actually draw
and show that we have actually taken
instructions to some extent from this
document and I think that's very very
important to give to give our residents
confidence that when any other issues
and options and any other documents go
out to them it's not going to be a
feeling that gonna end in a bin these
are actually going to be used and I
think we need to make sure our residents
understand we want to reference their
views I'm sure that you know we as
counselors will make sure that that this
is endorsed I have no problem with that
at all so the recommendation
sorry phrase only members can ask
questions
Gong Kris Thank You chairman
the the the overall from what I hear the
overall thing is that from residents is
their concerns are not taken so much
into consideration in the way of you
know I know we've we've we've got
planning policies and what-have-you but
90% of the people we're out there out of
the office of the plot strategic council
don't believe that that they're taking
into consideration and and what their
views are and I don't mean I agree with
that with with the with the outline that
we've just spoke about but we need to
emphasize that we do care for what they
say and we do take notice and to prove
that we do we need to publicize that
proof also now more so now than anything
else because of what's going on in the
in the in the district completely
because I feel that councilor Stanley
that's our job we're counselors yes
that's what we should be doing yes we
should be representing our residents we
should be making sure that they're their
feelings and views are projected to
whatever issue it be I don't have any
problem with that whatsoever the only
area that you sometimes run into
problems is where
technicalities and planning and other
issues to a degree tie our hands in what
we can actually enforce proposed action
but the principle of reflecting County
residents views that's it's a
fundamental part of being councilor I
have no problem that at all that's
exactly what what yeah is required of us
if you like I quite agree but as you say
there are rules there are regulations
that we have to go by and and that the
council has to go by which I've many a
time about Conservation's with Mike
strengths on on several planning issues
and believe you maybe this is explained
it but the resident the resident doesn't
quite mean I do broadcast that to the
resident that that's involved but they
still don't see why or what force just
you know they're like go back goes back
again they don't need that is for us yes
counselors to talk to them to see
residents to discuss issues and if
necessary explain it in in detail but at
the end of the day we have been elected
to represent their views yeah you know
it's what we should do we should yeah
thank you last one mr. walz very much
yeah I I think in regards to the point
you just made I think a good explanation
not only as to why we can do things but
actually as to why we can't do things
there are certain things that that we
just can't do no matter you know what
they want us to do there are certain
prohibit stations
I guess that stop us and I think we need
to be plain and honest with our own
residence we need to tell them the facts
and not be afraid to tell them the facts
thank you okay remembers but the
recommendation for this item is that the
the issues and options feedback report
is noted as an evidence-based document
and published on the council's website
that we agreed thank you can I just
thank Sean Sonya and particularly down
for his efforts in in compiling all
these reports today and we'll close the
meeting at 11:01 thank you very much
[Music]
you